the Lenovo IdeaPad s 940 is a fantastic
looking Windows laptop honestly one of
the best the display is very nice the
keyboard is a joy to type on but with
all that said for the asking price we
would suggest looking elsewhere because
of a few different things that really
stand out to us but along with that
there's also a specific group of people
that will absolutely enjoy this laptop
and I'll cover that in just a bit
there's also a way that you could save a
good amount of money if you're trying to
buy one of these I'll be covering that
as well now it's obvious that we are Mac
fans around here and coming from that
background I have to say that I love the
design it's a very MacBook without
copying a MacBook in fact many will
actually even prefer this design I love
how the front and the back kind of
sloped forward and the little minimally
beveled edges on the inside along with
that I really like how the badging is
very minimal right here at the lower
bottom side on both the lid and on the
inside as well if I can get this thing
open there you go with that we have a
slightly curved and shaped bezel all
around presenting a flat portion right
over here that makes it really easy to
open and with a nice 9 Series logo
elegantly embossed the unibody aluminum
chassis feels great in the hand but has
a bit too much flex for our liking and
the overall build quality is below
apple's with some misaligned panels the
touchpad is a decent size with very good
almost uniform clicking but cursor
control is below average at the top
right we have a slim power button with
LED indicator which doesn't include a
fingerprint scanner but that's totally
fine by us
since the s 940 offers Windows hello
facial unlocking that we absolutely love
below the 720p HD webcam in the IR
sensor our model has a gorgeous non
touch 500 nits 100% srgb 4k display
capable of HDR playback but there is
also a 400 nits 1080p option that will
help with battery life but more on
battery in just a bit the quad speakers
are user-facing with Dolby tuning and
sound above average for an ultra-light
Windows laptop surprising 2.6 pounds in
this case but it can't keep up with
Apple's $1100 MacBook Air
or similarly priced 13-inch MacBook Pros
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at the center is probably the best
feature of the laptop and that is the
backlit keyboard the key travel is just
long enough to feel great but still stay
thin and with enough pressure required
to eliminate mist types without feeling
too clicky and with dampening without
being too mushy if you type a lot this
is one of the best keyboards and any
laptop that is this thin in light on the
sides we have a headphone mic combo jack
along with three ports to being full
speed Thunder both three and the other
USB type-c but for some reason it's only
USB see gen1 meaning that the speed is
only half of what it could be now being
macbook fans we're used to only having
USB type-c ports but it still is a bit
disappointing to see a $2000 laptop with
less ports than apple's equivalent that
gets so much hate for being a dongle
book our s 940 has 512 gigabytes of nvme
SSD running at a super-fast 3341
megabytes per second read and 1939
megabytes per second write which is
refreshing compared to other ultra books
that skimp on SSDs so far this lenovo is
sounding very good overall but this is
where I have to get to the few weak
spots of this beautiful ultra book and
even though there's not that many of
them to clean about these can really
make or break your decision first off
the webcam both looks poor and sounds
really muffled this is an audio and
video quality test on the lenovo ideapad
s 940 second is the battery life it
makes sense that lenovo could only fit a
52 watt hour battery in this ultra-thin
machine but pairing it to a 500 nits 4k
display results in really poor battery
life lenovo rates it at seven-and-a-half
hours of battery life which in the real
world is closer to 5 hours with usable
display brightness levels if you want to
go with a very color accurate gorgeous
HDR displays this places it at the
bottom of the market for battery life
now opting for the 1080p display will
about double battery life
that's a big trade-off since it's not as
bright and it's much lower quality
overall personally we wish they would
have split it right in the middle like
Huawei or Apple with the resolution kind
of between 1080p and a 4k that will
still give you a detailed image and ten
hours of battery life while maintaining
500 nits of brightness but instead you
have to choose from a top-notch bright
4k display with poor battery life or an
average 1080p display with good battery
life and that choice is hard to make the
last downside is the performance the
spec sheet sounds very promising with an
HM quad-core 1.8 gigahertz i7 processor
that can boost all the way up to 4.6
gigahertz but running a few tests gave
us disappointing results the similarly
priced 13-inch MacBook Pro scored about
40 percent higher in Geekbench 4 and
almost 60 percent higher in Cinebench
r20 where all of the cores are maxed out
even though the MacBook is an i5 CPU not
an i7 even comparing it to a $1,300 base
1.4 gigahertz I 5 macbook pro the lenovo
s 940 falls really far behind how is
that possible you may ask well the CPUs
and both these machines are rated at 15
watts but the lenovo is not letting the
i7 run higher than that where the
MacBook can continuously run at about 30
watts and yes that's what all of the
power saving features turned off and
with the s 940 plugged in while the
MacBook Pros are on battery power
without having to find and change any
power options other Windows laptops
don't limit the CPU as much but I could
see why lenovo is doing this given the
power draw of the brag 4k display and
because of the smaller battery capacity
processor performance isn't the only
downside but the Intel UHD graphic 620
did struggle a bit with the 4k display
causing occasional UI stutters and also
sometimes when playing back 4k YouTube
videos of course the same GPU is used in
most Windows equivalents but most of
those have lower resolutions and the
1080p version of the s 940 shouldn't
have these issues now on the Mac side
Apple pays more for Intel chips with
iris graphics which provide more than
double the performance as you can see
here in our Geekbench OpenCL test these
downsides paired with
$2,000 MSRP make the s 940 a laptop
that's hard to recommend even though we
really like a lot about it this is a
really nice aluminum ultra-thin and
light machine with only USB type-c ports
and a gorgeous display at a premium
price almost like you're buying a
Windows version of a macbook we did
decide by side comparison that you can
check out by using a card at the end of
this video and the MacBook Pro has much
better performance has four Thunderbolt
3 ports much better speakers and
trackpad a better webcam it has touch ID
instead of Windows hello and about
double the battery life while having an
almost a sharp display with better color
accuracy and similar brightness you
don't have HDR for videos and the
keyboard is a ways behind but overall it
provides a much better value for the
price now the main reason why we're
comparing it to a macro pro is because
lenovo prioritized many things that
Apple does and at a similar price point
but of course not everybody wants a Mac
and that's where the new XPS 95 80 or
razor blade stealth come in both having
better port options improved performance
and a lower regular price which make the
s 940 a hard sell but there is one
redeeming factor and that's the good
discounts that Lenovo offers on their
own website which we will link down in
the description
prices do change me right now the $1,800
model is 360 dollars off which is still
only $60 cheaper than a similarly
equipped MacBook Pro but at least at
that price I can actually recommend it
to one group of people those who do a
lot of typing for most people even at
that price a MacBook or XPS is probably
a better choice but if you prioritize
design and want a thin and light Windows
laptop that has a gorgeous screen to
look out while you type away at the top
notch keyboard for up to five hours at a
time the lenovo s 940 will be a
fantastic laptop for your needs but if
you care about performance battery life
ports and value more than you do design
then you should look elsewhere thank you
guys for watching this has been max max
tech go ahead and click that little
circle above if you guys want to
subscribe and enable those notifications
below and if you want to see our full
comparison of the lenovo s 940 against
the similar price macbook pro you guys
can click right
for their thanks for watching and I will
see you guys in the next video
[Music]